what's up guys welcome back to
GameSpot's things you missed
as always I'm Tim Geddes and this is
Nick's therapy and Aloha from kind of
funny today we're looking at fantastic
beasts and where to find them the new
trailer set in the Harry Potter universe
universe we're back baby and you hear it
can you hear it let it in baby that goes
so you you're big you're the Harry
Potter guy I of our group out of our
group yes I love Harry Potter I'm glad
that we're getting more Harry Potter
because more Harry Potter is always good
it's more magic always a good thing and
this trailer is chock full of goodies ok
ok any Harry Potter fan right let's get
right into let's jump right into it ok
so we start off and we see or rather we
hear
the famous incantation I'm not exactly
famous but it harkens back to beginning
a Prisoner of Azkaban where Harry is
sitting underneath his blanket and
practicing that specifically yes as an
incantation remember I should say and of
course then it blows up logo and this of
course here let's pause right there
these are some amazing magical streaks
now the first time I looked at this I
was like ok that looks a lot like the
Patronus spell mm-hmm you know that
famous defense a defensive maneuver that
Harry Potter does is but it could just
be the most mad got it ok ok but that
usually generally you know lights up the
entire room I don't know that we've ever
seen it with necessarily with the
streets and stuff like that it is very
very reminiscent yeah but you're spot-on
this is very reminiscent of that opening
scene of Prisoner of Azkaban and I like
little Limoges like that so so this is
not necessarily a prequel series what
what is this exactly this isn't this is
an extended sort of story in the world
of Harry Potter
uh-huh so this is happening roughly 72 I
think 70 to 80 years before the Harry
Potter series starts this is happening
in the 20s
famously this is a it centers around
we're gonna see him shortly Newt
Scamander who is a magic wall ojas
that's a long try say that were three or
four that is why basically he's a
zoologist in the magic goddess he goes
around he's been commissioned in the
ninth in 19 1918 to write a book called
fantastic beasts and we find them all
right it all comes to guess actually
comes
roughly a year after this story
supposedly take this supposed to take
place let's keep going through here so
we're seeing this of course the more
important about to fly through it like
we always do of course you love to eat
we didn't in and the first images of
things we're seeing here let's pause it
right here now this gets me very excited
uh-huh and here's why because when I was
a kid a wee boy of probably about 20 to
25 got it I was reading Harry Potter yes
and I always wondered what the wizarding
world would look like in America yeah
they've made it they've made allusions
to it and then talked about you know the
President of the United States things
like that so we exist yeah Mary Potter
work ok ok it's just so much of it was
caught up in the UK and that's fine but
now it's coming home mmm that's coming
home and so we're seeing for the first
time here this is one of the main
characters soon to be you know later
down the line I think this is the love
interest for Newt Scamander and
eventually going to be his wife not
really cute spoilers there well how do
you know that is that from the fantastic
beasts book or is that from Harry Potter
that is from Harry Potter because they
have eventually well I guess it's
probably sort of expanded universe at
this point but eventually their grandson
marries Linda love good who was a main
character in Harry Potter ok so but I
mean in the Harry Potter books and
movies we don't really see these
characters ok the Harry Potter books and
movies they read the book yes it's a
textbook basically given to them and I
believe that during sports for stones
first to your textbook okay and you get
it it's sort of a reference guide to
where to find these and these fantastic
bees got it okay you know hippocras it's
written by this newt guy it's written by
a newt scamander and so he's visiting
with America right so he went to
Hogwarts graduate of Hogwarts visiting
America and he brings the suitcase that
we're seeing here okay okay so that's a
suitcase that he is brought that is
filled with fantastic fantastic beasts I
know where to find him Nick you do know
where to find mouse it's presumably this
suitcase has an undetectable extension
curse on it
which is what was famously used
throughout the series we saw you know
during Goblet of Fire when they were at
the Quidditch matches and they walked
into the small tent and also it was a
mansion Hermione Granger used it later
in the series and the Deathly Hallows
where you know she would just keep
pulling things out of this little tiny
bag like there's swords Ogata gum and so
so we've seen this before but we assume
that once you know there's more room in
that case the
and meets the appendix the I let's keep
going here and so we're seeing for the
first time some text here 2016 yeah boy
we're gonna get this but let's there we
go so we're seeing for the first time
this what the American Wizard
Association we might look like and this
is the magical Congress of the United
States of America which you see on the
symbol in the crest right behind them
right now a couple things to point out
here something that you pointed out with
you Allison one it looks like an eagle
but also a little like Athena exactly we
really kind of see it on her chair
behind her too it's clearly fire
underneath this Eagle Phoenix right now
obviously America there's a lot of Eagle
symbolism right we love water a lot of
v-not symbolism so that's it's pretty
cool and what also I found really
interesting is the amount of stars on
the same canvas stuff so I can't so and
sorry at this point because it's the 20s
their art isn't the 50 states yet ma you
know fully in there so it's only at 48
okay so like that's represented here but
what I find really interesting is that
in the Eagle there's not that many stars
but you can find the others above him
kind of scattered I don't know what this
means
I don't know if there is a difference
between maybe maybe there is magic in
some of the states not the other writers
or I I don't know I'm totally just
stretching here but like there has to be
some symbolism of why the stars are
separated gotcha
now so we're seeing poor patina who was
one of the main characters here it's
kind of presenting to the to this
Congress hey there's something wrong now
is that the president that is that
should be the president yeah okay the
poor man so do you assume that it's the
president of magic yes was there another
president or doe is the dog president we
assume that she is like the Minister of
Magic okay we assume she's basically the
head of whatever governing body which in
this case was probably the Congress the
United States of the magical Congress
rather she is the head of whatever this
governor is but there is a president of
America there is a president of United
States
so if Rollins of purposes in the 2004
the president column would kill me yeah
the president wasn't about it but for
all intensive purposes during the Harry
Potter era it was the whoever the
monetary president what got it so this
is supposedly happening in the real
world which in America apparently in UK
you know obviously across the world
no one knows like anyone in the in the
as they're called non-magic people don't
really know that there's magic in the
world okay and they go to great lengths
in the UK to sort of hide that from them
but there's no animosity necessarily
between the two groups there's a little
bit of hatred on the fringes of you know
a little bit of discrimination between
muggles and magicians but here in the
20s they're setting up more of a world
where we're seeing a little bit of the
Wizards living in fear of being um okay
is that in the UK men America oh just
know about 20s but in America here we're
seeing sort of they're alluding to the
fact that there are organizations out
there and JK Rowling's has come out and
said that there's it's going to center
around a group of people called no
matches and so no - Maj Allison's a bit
I don't match no magics who are out to
basically ferret out the Wizards Diane's
pretty much drive Madison sighs okay
okay okay so be it's the enemy of these
guys any of these guys right cool so the
Makua is that a thing that was talked
about in in Harry Potter which is the
the magical Congress of the United
States of America no I mean potentially
potentially not that I remember about
okay I know that okay it's a possibility
and here we're seeing that suitcase see
who the first look at our boy Newt Newt
Scamander that is the suitcase that he
brings in New York which causes all the
trouble
no here all right there we go
this is awesome this is Colin Farrell's
first roaster his graves graves the
character that is the president's
assistant right so I'm gonna sue me
based on his look and just based on kind
of what's going on here I'm making the
jump that he is like all right he's the
one that's tasked to find those guys
that are trying to you know show
everyone the wizard and stop them right
so so so presumably the entire story
centers around that case and that we
know that Dan Fogle is character jacob
kowalski is a muggle or an oh man who
has accidentally let some creatures out
and we can see here the devastation that
they've caused a grave seemingly is
probably tasked you're right by the by
the president of the Congress to go
after these creatures and figure out
what the hell's going on here although
he looks a little evil to me just
putting it out there I mean I don't know
if he's gonna be a good guy or bad yeah
we'll see I'm with a name like graves so
the name I graves
probably a bad guy
but we'll see here you got that huh how
does that make you feel that makes me
feel so good yeah
like it looks like the cobblestone
streets of Diagon Alley or it maybe have
graphs again I'm not quite sure I don't
know I forget which one has scales
just a little bit of a smidge of a
character some of these creatures have
gotten out and yeah presumably all hell
is going to break so what was that spell
there do you know I don't know that
spell presumably one of the incantations
that freezes people okay okay but it
looks like he's attacking something yeah
it's well it was probably a charm that
one of the freezing tribes but I'm not
quite sure you never okay okay it could
be a disarming charm but these are
creatures so you're probably gonna want
to stop them okay cool right God and
then here we're seeing the logo for the
first well not the first we're seeing a
logo in action the famous sort of liquid
flying the letters and yeah of course
you know those blue flames of fire as a
dope don't blow to that posit I don't
real quick let's go back I'm like it
like look at that the S kinda looks like
a dragon yeah it looks like a dragon or
a basilisk tail or so you know so it's I
like that they're expanding it and I
like the way more Harry Potter even
though it's not miss its not Harry
Potter okay but this is the best we got
yeah and you know how you go with it I
think that they they know what they're
doing obviously movie universities are
kind of the in thing right now and they
will be for the coming years and I think
that you know Harry Potter in a lot of
ways was one of the big founders of that
I think we're just in the fact that it's
a it was a movie franchise that lasted
it was not just a trilogy right yes like
up until Harry Potter most things were
just truly yeah he has like Lord of the
Rings trilogy is you at Star Wars
children and that was really kids or a
fantastic trilogy or I'm sorry fantasy
trilogy would generally stick to about
free movies yeah she blew it out of the
water when I say she I ever for cuteness
take a wrong turn you when she decided
to make Harry Potter's
call her schooling career seven years
yes seven movies
eight movies so you know this is kind of
them being like all right you guys are
all doing this universe thing we can do
that - well it's awesome because just
like Star Wars there's so much mythology
that she built up in these stories so
many different aspects that when you
were reading the books or watching
movies you're like that's fascinating I
would have any more about that you know
obviously like the for instance like
Nicholas Flamel the person that you know
the guy this me the Sorcerer's Stone
stories like that they're like I would
actually like to see more of that so
let's start adding to that in the world
and my guess is she's going to do more
yeah definitely I mean I think there's a
lot a lot
are coming and I have a feeling that
these these move even have a lot more
references to the Harry Potter that we
know and love I would assume so as we
see more how it is himself
ladies and gentlemen yeah that's the
things you missed in the fantastic
beasts and where to find them true do we
miss anything let us know in the
comments below
until next time thank you very much for
joining us you can follow me on twitter
at tim Gettys you can follow this guy
we're at Nick underscore scarpino I'm so
sorry that you have that underscore name
what you gonna do it pains me I know it
happens little known fact about Newt
Scamander hufflepuff really yeah I know
it's perfect